extremists have long known that the
Internet is a place where mindsets and
behaviors can be shaped but to challenge
the sermons of hatred and the propaganda
videos calling for jihad a new character
has stepped into this domain he is a
cartoon called Abdullah X and his
mission is to win young minds by
directly challenging radical beliefs you
have to kill others to make your world
pure this is what you think his armies
are you for real
his creator has never been interviewed
before and doesn't want to be identified
I have the knowledge the background and
the experience to understand that
narratives such as the one driven by
extremist groups have beaten mainstream
society in in access to the Internet
they have beaten mainstream society in
content in the ability to justify what
they stand for and what they believe in
and I felt - in 2012 for example when I
started this project that unless we make
a proactive step to take some of that
ground back online it will never embed
itself in the offline reality of young
people the man behind Abdullah X knows
this because he himself was a former
hardline extremist who followed the
sermons of preachers such as Abu Hamza
and Omar Bakri and was a member of
banned extremist groups his character is
also a disillusioned Muslim but on his
cartoon journey comes to realize violent
jihad is not the answer
how did you come to that conclusion
because you you obviously used to think
the other way
I came to that conclusion probably
through a mixture of two realizations
one the people spewing out this message
90% of them didn't have the heart or
conviction to go and do anything like
this themselves you mean how hamza
backery those kind of people certainly
individual certainly individuals that
I've come into contact with who adopted
the mantra of being a sheikh or a
scholar ultimately became the same
individuals who were happy to claim
government benefits I realized therefore
that unless I'm confident that I have
the appropriate picture of my faith I
will always be seeing it through the
lens of these kind of people that was
that took me a long time to understand
last week Sky News spoke to a Londoner
wanting to fight in Syria having been
influenced by the call to jihad in
videos online and what's innovative
about this project is it sits in the
place where young Muslims might seek
answers to questions about jihad do you
genuinely think that going out there to
fight and potentially be killed will
affect those suffering in a positive way
it offers an alternative to
radicalization but cuts a fine line you
get democracy or get hypocrisy you get
margin for error we get the label of
terror
he hopes to save the lives of young
Muslims who believe that jihad has
become some call of duty that is
mimicked for them through their
PlayStation experience that they now
think they can do for real in some
far-off land for a cause they don't
truly understand and furthermore it
hopefully starts to expel myths and
stereotypes and prejudices that
non-muslims may have about Islam because
the only Islam they hear about is one
that they tend to fear nowadays and the
Creator believes that some who have
followed the journey of Abdullah X have
as a result veered from quite a
different journey into radicalization
Jason Farrell Afghan youth